dawn and mike pompeo's on a mission a
mission that didn't go quite the way he
planned
pompeo has been on the road for the past
week rallying support for washington's
iran policy
last wednesday he abruptly pulled out of
a scheduled meeting with germany's
chancellor angela merkel
instead he met iraqi leaders and warned
them that iran's threat to american
interests in the region was growing
he then postponed a trip to russia to
share iran intelligence with european
leaders in brussels
but they didn't offer him their backing
on the european union side on the member
states of the european union side
there's full determination to do all we
can as i said with all our instruments
to implement at full our part
of the nuclear agreement as long as iran
remains compliant
next stop sochi in the russian black sea
resort
pompeo met president vladimir putin and
foreign minister sergey lavrov
but again he got very little
we didn't support it and we consider it
a mistake that the u.s
exited the iran nuclear deal
we hope to find a political solution to
the situation in iran
and we'll try to assist so that the
situation
doesn't turn into a military scenario
in recent days the us has considerably
increased its military presence in the
persian gulf
but pompeo denies that the trump
administration is preparing for war
we're looking for iran to behave like a
normal country
and that's our ask and we have applied
pressure to
the leadership of the islamic republic
of iran to achieve that we
we fundamentally do not see a war
with iran iran's leadership also denies
its heading for conflict
now pompeo has returned to washington on
his european tour allies and rivals
alike
warned him against war well let's get
some analysis now as
sasha lohman america expert at the
german institute for international
security affairs welcome to the show
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me
is this the start of a de-escalation in
the gulf well i feel no
these processes are hardly controllable
and it's
a huge potential for misperception so
steps on both sides are perceived
to be offensive even if they're
essentially meant to be defensive
do you think it's it's reassuring tehran
nonetheless that pompeo's been out there
talking to people talking to russia
talking to the eu well i think it's kind
of reassuring that he's so far
unsuccessful unsuccessful to garner
support for the so-called maximum
pressure strategy but at the same time
the u.s is deploying new military assets
in the region and i think that's highly
um unstabilizing for also the iranian
leadership
what do you think about this uh shuttle
diplomacy on on pompeo's behalf
is it a one-off effort or do you think
america will be keeping
up the pressure for this maximum
pressure strategy that that you just
mentioned
well basically pompeo is trying to
garner some legitimacy
from allies in europe but also from
partners of the remaining
parties among the jcpoa but he must not
be successful necessarily because the
u.s can
enhance snapback sanctions unilaterally
and they are pressuring to run
regardless of what the others do and
their efforts at trying to save the deal
so far have
also been proven not successful at all
okay well the administration in
washington believes that the sanctions
will strengthen the opposition
undermine the regime of the muellers
could they though wind up
strengthening the hard landliners in
iran
sure i mean those are the the two
theories and it looks like as the the
second theory um that it's strengthening
the heart line as the so-called rally
round the flag theory is actually
what's happening on the ground in tehran
okay
as part of that rally around the flag
theory in tehran we've seen
a deployment of of iranian assets in the
gulf
as well including the um the elite units
of the republican guard
what are the iranians doing uh for their
side now to to strengthen their position
in the gulf militarily
well they're trying to put some pressure
on the us at the same time because they
cannot match up militarily
on the scale with the u.s navy and the
persian gulf so what they're doing is
that they are trying to
somehow retaliate asymmetrically and
that's why they're deploying
some assets so-called proxies in the
region and this also heightens the
potential for escalation because of the
proximity
between u.s forces in syria and in iraq
and these iranian-backed forces just
this morning we we have
reports coming in from iran that iran
has indicated the country has already
stopped some of its commitments under
the nuclear deal
what impact do you think that could have
well those are
fairly small steps and they are also
only pertaining to these areas that the
u.s
reimposed sanctions on um so these are
actually steps which indicate that the
iranian leadership
is still interested in maintaining the
deal and we will see after the
so-called ultimatum to the europeans to
60 days
what they will do afterwards because
it's not really likely that the
europeans
can actually deliver economic
benefits to iran because u.s sanctions
are prohibiting european companies even
in europe to follow
eu law and with the economic threats and
pressures
increasing and with the military threats
and pressures increasing as well
what needs to be done right now to cool
the situation off
to get an effective de-escalation well
as i said these processes are hardly
controllable and what needs to be done
is
there needs to be an actor that might be
able to de-escalate the situation but in
this kind of environment it's really
hard to actually
send signals of the escalation because
the potential for misperception
is so huge so i think this is kind of
what's really dangerous about this whole
situation that there's hardly
a kind of space for for de-escalation
okay briefly if you could who should be
the interlocutor
you just mentioned could it be the
europeans well preferably the europeans
but so far they're really
cautious in kind of getting the united
states
to really accept that they want to
maintain the deal and
kind of put some put some money where
their mouth is
sasha lowman america expert at the
german institute for international
security affairs thanks for coming in
this morning thanks
you